in this tutorial I will show you how to
write a custom HPC toolkit blueprint
from scratch
I will assume you already have some high
level familiarity with HPC toolkit
Concepts if you have not already done so
I recommend you first watch the previous
videos in this series Linked In the
description below
it's a way to customize a blueprint is
to start with an example provided in the
HPC toolkit GitHub repository
from the repos main page we can click on
examples to see a full list of examples
from this table of contents we can click
on a specific example to read more
details and click through again to see
the actual blueprint
today we are going to start from scratch
so you can see how One of These
Blueprints gets built up I will be
working in the cloud shell editor where
I have already installed the HPC toolkit
ghpc command line tool
the previous simple cluster tutorial
video has instructions to get you this
far
I will be building a blueprint that
Provisions two shared file systems and
then uses them with a batch job my
blueprint will include a new VPC Network
a file store for shared software and a
ddn exascaler luster high performance
file system the blueprint will also
include a batch job template module that
will automatically Mount these file
systems on a batch job finally I will
add a batch login node that can be used
to test and submit the batch job the
blueprint will contain a reference to
each of these modules and describe how
they are interconnected
on the examples readme page I can find a
boilerplate template for a new blueprint
I will start by copying this template
and filling out some basic information
we need to populate the blueprint name
and deployment name
the blueprint name should remain the
same over time it is applied as a label
to resources and can be used to track
usage and costs associated with the
blueprint
the deployment name should be unique for
each instance of a blueprint that you
deploy
this is used to name Cloud resources
like VMS and disks and can be updated to
avoid naming clashes
I will leave project ID empty and
overwrite this value on the command line
let's start by adding the VPC module to
our blueprint
to do this we need to view its
documentation page we can find a full
list of supported modules under the
modules folder
this list is broken down by roll we are
looking for the VPC module under the
networking role
each module has documentation containing
a simple example snippet that can be
copied as a starting point to build our
blueprint the network name setting is
optional and to keep this blueprint
simple I'm just going to remove it
next we'll add our two shared file
systems to our blueprint
we can find the file store documentation
under the file system role just like
with our VPC module we will copy the
example snippet into our blueprint this
file store will be a place to install
shared applications and will be
available from our batch job
the ddnx scalar luster module is also
found under the file system role again
we will copy the example snippet
my batch job will use this luster as a
High Performance Scratch file system
now in my blueprint I have a network and
two shared file systems next we can
start to customize these modules
each module has a list of inputs that we
can Define using the settings field
we can see that file store and luster
have a local Mount setting that has been
pre-populated
a full list of supported settings and
their description can be found on the
modules documentation page under inputs
for example we see that the file store
local Mount setting is optional and will
default to Shared if not specified
foreign let's update the file store
local Mount so that it mounts under apps
it is worth noting that all matching
deployment variables will be propagated
down to module settings so for example
file store has required region and Zone
settings
but I can leave them blank as I have
defined a region and Zone deployment
variable the module ID is what we will
use to reference a module from within
the blueprint we can rename the file
store module to reflect that it will be
our applications file system
next I will add a batch job template
module and a batch login node module to
our blueprint
both of these modules are found under
the scheduler role
the first of these will generate a batch
job template file which can be used to
submit a batch job on Google Cloud by
using the HPC toolkit the batch job will
automatically Mount the shared file
systems next I will add a batch login
node this module will provision a VM
that contains the batch template file
created in the previous module
additionally it will automatically Mount
the same shared file systems this makes
the batch login node a great place from
which to test submit and monitor batch
jobs
now we can wire the modules together we
do this with the use field by connecting
the modules with the use field the HPC
toolkit will automatically pass
variables between the modules where
output and variable names match
some modules are already correctly
configured due to the default naming of
the example Snippets we copied from
for example file store and luster are
correctly using Network 1 which is the
ID for our VPC Network let's update our
batch job to have access to both our
file systems to do this we will add the
ID of each file system to the use field
of the batch job module we can now use
the ghpc create command to generate a
deployment folder and deployer
infrastructure
as mentioned previously we can use the
vars command line argument to overwrite
deployment variables I will use it here
to dynamically set the project ID
deploying the infrastructure takes
several minutes and when it is finished
we will see printed instructions on how
to SSH into our batch login node and
submit our batch job
now that our infrastructure has been
deployed what if I want to make changes
to my blueprint for example I want to
use a different image for my batch job
I will add an image setting to the batch
job module so that it will use a rocky 8
image the full list of module settings
and their defaults can be found for each
module on its documentation page here
I'm copying in the image information but
there's a link in the description on how
to find available images we can redeploy
our blueprint to reflect this change by
adding the dash W argument ghpc will
overwrite my existing deployment
directory while preserving the terraform
State this allows me to safely apply
updates from my blueprint
well now I am off and running ready to
use batch with my HPC toolkit deployment
hopefully with the skills and resources
you learned about in today's video you
can feel confident customizing
Blueprints and even building your very
own from scratch